[Music] An
earthquake came upon us and destroyed our entire house to the ground.
Then came the holy month of Ramadan. We went for a while and got what we needed
from the market, but Ramadan is not like
last year, and this year has become difficult for us. This year has become difficult
for us, meaning our psychology has been broken and we have come to sit in
the tent as well.
[Music]
The month of Ramadan is good, my husband. I mean, it is very difficult.  It's very
difficult. It's just what you say, Lord of the Worlds.
[Music] [
Music] I
mean, we're homeless and there's no stability. I mean,
I'm helpless. Happy New Year. We're not fine at all, and we're not comfortable with the choice. I mean, what can I tell you? This is the bread I settled so I can make a living
from it and live for the rest of my life.  Every day
when I, my wife, and my children eat and drink, there is no one to help
but God
[Music]